you're live chairman
good evening and welcome everybody to
this southeast area
planning committee meeting on wednesday
the 17th of march 2021
my name is councillor nick skeens and
i'm the chairman of this committee
this meeting is held under new
regulations which came into effect on
the 4th of april last year in response
to
clovid 19 situation please can i ask
everyone present in this meeting to
ensure your camera remains
on where broadband permits and your
microphone remains
muted if you could all mute your
microphones please
especially when you're not addressing
the committee this will reduce
background noises and avoid
any unintentional disturbances uh we are
streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and so by
being present in the meeting
you are giving your consent to being
recorded members and officers during
each item please use the hands up
function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak you are reminded that apart
from
indicating points of order or that you
have to leave the meeting the chat
function
should not be used for questions or any
other purpose
except if you arrive at the meeting if
you arrive at the meeting late or you
know somebody has arrived late it would
be
good to if you could let people know
there so
that i think it's fairly clear we're
speaking when speaking and referring to
the agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page or paragraph number
and keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible and when
invited to speak please ensure you turn
on your microphone
it's so easy to forget and now if i may
ask
officers taking part in the meeting to
introduce themselves starting with uh
matt lee
good evening members i am matthew lee
lead specialist place and chief plan
officer
at morgan district council thank you
thank you matt michael johnson
good evening members i'm michael johnson
lead specialist development management
thank you
thank you catherine matthews
good evening chairman i'm catherine
matthews specialist in development
management thank you
thank you uh haley parker haynes
good evening members i'm hayley
parker-haynes and i and i'm a senior
caseworker here at malden
district council thank you thank you
louise staplehurst
good evening members i'm louise
stapleheart and i'm a specialist
in development management thank you
casey good evening members bernie casey
clark to this evening's committee
thank you any other officers present
tara bird was here earlier yeah she's in
she's
backup support okay great thank you okay
well before i call on the clerk to take
the roll call of committee members can i
ask those counselors in attendance
that is to say not part of the committee
but just listening in
to introduce themselves please
good evening everybody councillor morris
is here
and can i just um um suggest that
council of bassinger sorts out his
collar believe your collars up
that'll bug me for the whole meeting
yes okay thank you very much uh oh no
thank you uh and uh are there any other
counsellors in attendance
no okay uh berna can you please now
carry out a roll call of members
to confirm who is in attendance thank
you
thank you chairman members i will call
your names in alphabetical order can you
please indicate your attendance
starting with councillor bassinger thank
you good evening everyone i'm present
thank you counselor beale
cozmo beale councillor bell
good evening everyone i'm present
it counts the voice um here
but i don't know for how long i've got
connectivity problems
i'm trying to follow this on my phone
i had no hand function um
and other problems like very little
sound
thank you council boys councillor
channel
uh good evening chairman good evening
officers and members i'm present
like council advice i had a bit of
trouble getting in but hopefully
touchwood i'll be okay now but if not
you know why how's the duke yes hello
good evening what i'm present
thank you council helm presenter
yes i'm here thank you counselor stamp
present thank you members
thank you chairman thank you uh members
please be advised that we have one
public participant in this meeting this
evening uh
and i will call on him to speak at the
appropriate time please note that he
will be in the meeting with both his
camera and microphone off until the
decision is made
when we come to his agenda item in short
so
apologies for absence may i have those
apologies please berna
we've received no apologies for absence
chairman but as you noted councillor
beale is not yet
in the meeting so thank you i have a
hand up from wendy stem
wendy go ahead so sorry chairman
councillor bill's trying to get in he's
having difficulty
logging in thank you very much
okay so uh on to the minutes of 17th of
february 2021
it's recommended the minutes of the
meeting held on that date
which are found on pages 7-12 are
approved
as a true and accurate record i so move
and if you wish to second that motion
could you unmute your microphone and
state your name now
the helm agreed thank you council helm
if any member wishes to raise
any matter of accuracy please use the
hands up function to indicate and i will
invite you to speak
i see nobody raising any hands berna can
you advise me you haven't seen anybody
have you
no chairman okay so would you like to
sorry
chairman seems to have her hand up now
it was there penny channel's channels no
i think i might have flicked that
sorry by mistake and it's back up again
but i'm sorry is it back up again
okay so do you have is everybody happy
to agree these by
ascent
okay thank you very much and berna will
you now take uh oh well you don't need
to take the vote now we're going to
declarations of interest
to disclose the existence and nature of
any disclosable
pecuniary interests other pecuniary
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regards to paragraph
six and two eight inclusive of the code
of conduct for members
and members are reminded that uh they
are also required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware
should the knees need a rise throughout
the meeting
and if any member has an interest to
declare will you please use the hands up
function now
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
and i see penny councillor chana's hand
up now so uh thank you chairman and that
is a genuine hand up
um yes non-petunia chairman as a member
of essex county council
who is consulted on planning
applications for matters under its remit
such as highways education
access matters like that chairman thank
you
thank you very much councillor bassinger
uh thank you chairman uh number cunery
um i
play tennis and i'm a member of the same
tennis club as the grandson of the owner
of the bradwell marina so non-bicunary
right thank you very much for clarifying
okay so we can now
uh move on to uh the next item item
five uh which is uh
twenty stroke zero double one six three
stroke
f u l or orchard cottage 36 mount view
crescent saint lawrence this is found on
pages 13
to 32 please note that a member's update
in relation to this application has been
circulated prior to the meeting
in a moment i'll call on the officer to
present this item uh if the officer
could um
halo parker baines just tell us what was
in the update that will help council
china who wasn't able to
see them and members a reminder that if
you wish to speak
on this item please make this known by
using the hands up function within the
meeting
i will then come to you in turn please
keep your points clear and succinct uh
ms parker hayes could you please present
the report
thank you chairman
planning permission is sought to
demolish the existing chalet bungalow
subdivide the plot and construct two
dwellings each dwelling would benefit
from its own access
the members update that was circulated
prior to this meeting was in relation to
a second consultation response received
from
the parish council however no new
material considerations or comments were
made from their previous
original and consultation response
by way of a verbal member's update a
condition ensuring the first floor
windows
to the northern side elevation of plot 1
and southern side elevation of plot 2
are obscure glazed and a non-opening
design was admitted from section 8 of
the report
this is the location plan
closed block plan
these are the existing elevations and
floor plan
these are the proposed elevations of
plot one
these are the floor plans for plot one
are the elevations for plot two
these are the four plot two
this is the proposed street scene
elevation
these are some photographs of the site
properties
here we are it should be noted that this
application is a resubmission of a
previously refused application
it was considered at the time of the
previous application the pro
the proposal would have an unacceptable
impact in relation to
to design and the impact on the
character and appearance of the area
neighbouring amenity and the immunity of
future occupants of the proposed
dwellings
parking and rams these are detailed
within section 3.2.7 of the office
report the following slides compare the
previously refused scheme to the current
application
these are the block plans as you can see
the rear projection of plot two
has been repositioned to the other side
of this proposed dwelling and the
distances between the dwellings and the
boundaries has also
increased due to the reduction in width
of the dwelling proposed by
this current scheme
these are the elevations for plot one as
you can see the proposed front dormer
has been removed and the rear dormer has
been altered to accommodate a pitched
roof alongside the reduction in width
and depth of the proposed dwelling under
this application
these are the floor plans for plot one
showing the internal reconfiguration of
the dwelling under this application
these are the elevations for plot two as
you can see the overall design of the
dwelling
largely remains the same besides the
relocation of the single story rear
projection and the reduction in width
and depth of the dwelling
under this current application
these are the floor plans for plot two
showing the internal reconfiguration of
the dwelling under this application
and these are the street scene
elevations which better demonstrate the
reduction in scale of the dwellings
due to the reduction in the scale of the
proposed dwellings and the sympathetic
design
the proposal is considered on balance to
have an acceptable impact on the
character and appearance of the
surrounding area
furthermore due to the internal
configurations of the dwellings the
reduction in height and the relocation
of the rear projection to plot two it is
no longer considered that the proposed
development would have an overbearing
impact or result in an unacceptable loss
of light to the neighbouring occupiers
or future occupants of the proposed
dwellings
furthermore the applicant has submitted
a legal agreement to ensure the
appropriate mitigation
in relation to rams can be secured
should the application be approved
it is therefore considered that on
balance the proposed development would
be acceptable
and therefore is recommended for
approval in line with the
recommended conditions and the condition
advised in the verbal update
thank you chairman thank you very much
uh right so we now move to
uh talk about this debate the pros and
cons um
uh but uh is there anybody who would
like to speak
on this item i see no hands
there are no strong opinions uh
uh councillor chana um thank you
chairman well i have called this one in
um
to committee um the officer
um made reference to the parish
council's views
um that this was i think over
development and
obviously they placed an objection about
the the development
um i have to say um the officer's report
does refer to this being on balance
and i'm not sure at the moment i'm
totally sure that
i feel that all matters um
but the previous reasons refusal have
been overcome
i think i'll tell you for a while i know
the officer's report states
that the frontage is around range from
around 11.9 to 18.6
meters but this is still quite a narrow
plot and looking at it and knowing
mount view um as i do and the various
designs i do feel
there's still an element of squeezing in
two dwellings onto a you know a small
site
and that does concern me and i
appreciate what the office has said
about
the moving of various elements um so
something has moved away from the
boundary and there's been
um i think some some reduction in height
and width
um etcetera and depth but i do still
have
some concerns about the overall design
and the uh you know the
inappropriate visual relationships with
immediate neighbors and
the surrounding area if i'm honest
um in what i see and
i think the officer's report said this
is one of the largest plots
um well it won't be when it's split and
we're talking about
accesses um for uh plot one i think no
width is going to be uh 4.5 meters and
plot two
4.3 meters um although it says
eight meters of verge between them is
that correct i think i'm i couldn't
quite though
that one out actually but um because
that's to me
is larger well
less than what the officer's report is
saying the width of the the site is
unless
my maths are wrong uh thank you very
much uh councillor channel can we
can i return to um uh haley parker
haynes could you
respond to councillor chana's uh
comments especially
about the width
thank you chairman i'll just get the
proposed block plan up um
and this should explain that two seconds
so the plot width i don't know if you
can see it here
um for each dwelling it's broken down
for you by the degree of separation from
plot 1 and plot 2 from the neighboring
properties there's 1.5 meters there
and then 6 meters and then
another 1.4 meters before the shared
boundary between the dwellings
so if my maths was good on point it's
um 8.95 meters
for each plot width
okay that's okay
okay yeah i was going by what
it um said there was a 4.5 meters
referred to
plot two four point three and eight
meters of verge between
which when i added all that up came to a
not quite the same as what the report
then said the whole width of the plot
was
and again my point is it says that it's
one of the largest in the areas
at 18 meters wide existing plot
um and uh frontage around
frontiers around range from 11.9 meters
to 18.6
i still feel that this is still trying
to squeeze in
two properties onto sort of a site
um and if you look can you put the block
plan up again please
sorry change it possible for cancer chad
just to clarify the paragraph she's
talking to so i just want to
start the at the start of the report
plot what starts off at that
plot 1 4.5 minutes very early on in the
report
plot 1 4.5 meters plot 2 4.3
found it at the beginning so i was
trying to look further down thank you
chancellor channel
so as you can see look at the size of
those
dwellings if you look at well
where are we i haven't really got the if
you look at those two dwellings going in
there
look at the the property uh there's a
slightly
what looks like a brown color ready
brown color to me the property on the
left there
and then look at the property on the
right where the little gray sort of
shaded
property is can you if you can see what
i'm getting to
here you've got very very tiny looking
properties as you'd see them from this
roads
street scene you're there the other
properties
seem to be bigger on mass so it seems to
me you're
trying to squeeze in or the planning
application is trying to squeeze in
two very small sort of properties
has have we got something this is the
block plan have we got a location plan
showing those two in there within the
wider area because there's a number of
um designs i know you showed the red
sort of
um planning application area without
these superimposed on
but i think that would have been quite
helpful as well although i suspect
they'd look so
quite small um that would really sort of
highlight where i'm sort of coming from
on this to me
that likes two very small properties and
we do need
new we do need smaller properties as i
guess one's two-bedroomed
but it just that to me looks as though
we're squeezing something in
um on a site okay uh uh
council channel thanks very much you've
made your point and i take your point
particularly that
i didn't see an elevation which would
have shown how those houses a street
scene
which showed how those houses fit in
that street scene
i don't recall that from the
presentation if there is one
uh miss parker haynes it would be good
if you could put that up
is there one are you aware of
not of the location plan with the two
dwellings shown
okay i'd like uh uh to invite anybody
else
uh who would like to speak on this and
then we shall move to a vote
uh councillor bell
thank you um mr chairman just really to
uh
to echo councillor china's concerns when
when i looked at this my first thought
was all two little lilly put houses for
the lilliputians to live in
amongst the ordinary sized homes and it
does
i don't know if contrived is the word
certainly squeezed in
but is that a sufficient
planning reason it's this it's this on
balance
thing again that i struggle with i
really do
because it's it's
fairly arbitrary and i'm i'm not
convinced
that on a planning basis that that is
enough
to uh to refuse this so i'm i'm really
i'm really torn on this one
thank you councillor bell councillor
helm
thank you mr chairman i agree with
everything that counselor canna has
said it's rather cramped and drived
contrived
uh between the two buildings there's two
meters but there's a fence in between
and a bit of greenery so i don't know
what gap you have to get to the back
garden
and then meet to the other side either
side so it's really cramped on this side
they're trying to squeeze everything on
and i think it's just that bit too much
thank you
okay thank you very much well uh i'm
going to
uh put forward a proposal uh and uh
councilmember if you could take your
hand down please that would be great um
thank you
uh that we uh in short uh go with the
audience
if possible if i just quickly come back
i think on a couple of points is that
okay i'm sorry yes of course i should
have
invited you that's fine
uh thank you uh ms park hanes it's
possible to call up the
street scene i think you did i think
because i didn't think about the schemes
ask if there was one i think there is
isn't there
yes diego counts members
that's right it's funny isn't it because
they've uh
put that in color the other two aren't
in color so it makes it look
bigger than but i understand that's i'm
not suggesting anything by that it just
is it is the impression but yes i
understand thanks very much
go ahead also can mr go to the first
slide on this presentation
i think that might help members with
relation to councillor chana's point
um about um as
the officer report states and as also
has been discussed the
plot widths in this area are quite
buried um
there is a mixture of quite small ones
down to actually relatively large ones
there is an eclectic and varied style of
properties and design
i think this is
proposing uh properties on a smaller
scale than what predominantly is within
the area but
as decision makers we have to decide
whether or not that would actually
result in demonstrable harm to the
character of the area
in an area where there is such a varied
and diverse
mix of property styles and designs so
that's just what i'd obviously
highlight to members taking into account
that you know we don't have a plug-in
supply and that will
way in favor of this com proposal
thank you chairman thank you uh
councillor chana has raised her hand
thank you chairman well that's my point
if okay we this is the best we've got
which is the the planning application
site
put a line virtually down the middle in
the application
site okay and then
think about those dwellings with the 1.5
meters either side
of the other dwellings which which says
in the report both are there's a
distance of 1.5 meter
plot one between the boundary plot two
minimum of 1.5 meters
so if you we've got to use our
imaginations i know but i did a rough
sketch if you put a line down the middle
um because it's only about 4.5 meters or
4.3 difference between
um those sort of areas
and imagine the 1.5 you you try and put
two little
two little dwellings on there and i
think you'll find when you see the other
the other blocks on on the respective
plots
those two will certainly be different
to anything i feel in that immediate
locality it will be a case
of two little blocks in there that's
right if you look at
either side you've got quite okay um
you might think um the width isn't quite
right um in fact i did question the
boundary lines at one time but
those dwellings either side look better
placed on their plots
it's a bit of a difference when you get
something divided that's relatively
okay like the report said 18 meters wide
but when you split that
and then put two little dwellings on
with the divisions in between those
dwellings as well let's not forget
as well as the 1.5 either side
it does make that look very tight
it's amazing thank you thank you very
much uh councillor china
uh i'm now going to propose make a
proposal uh
and i'm going to propose that uh we uh
that this committee uh approves
uh the uh application subject to
conditions
as detailed in section eight of this
report do i have a seconder
okay so i don't have a seconder so
therefore
we will move to um
somebody coming up with as an
alternative recommendation
does anybody have a a different proposal
well chairman um if you haven't got a
seconder
i suppose that means we have got to then
move a record
a proposal of
do refusal chairman if that's the case
if i'm correct on that if you haven't
got a seconder
and you can't move your proposal then
the only alternative
um would be refusal so you checked
the bill or did he
good evening sir um i was trying to get
uh into the
by using the yellow hand etc uh it
wasn't coming up but it has now
i'd be quite happy to propose uh to
second to the proposal made by
um was it was a channel
oh well uh sorry are you by yourself sir
yes okay so just to be clear you
are seconding uh the chairs uh
recommendations that we approve
subject conditions yes okay so
let's go to a photo on that if we can
please
um i don't suppose this is going to be
done by a cent since there's clearly
division on this
so if you could uh berna if you could
take a vote please
yes chairman members were voting for the
um recommendation the officer's
recommendation of approval
and can you please state clearly for
against or abstain
i will call your names in alphabetical
order
chancellor bassinger against
cancer deal for
that's the bell i have to abstain i'm
afraid
i wonder if you can hear us cancer boys
cancer channel um
against
i did something wasn't heard there could
you repeat please
counselor duik abstain
thank you for helping here
sorry chairman beside you that wasn't
heard
no no you were heard counseling okay
thank you
councillor was heard now we're on to
councillor helm i believe
again
abstain thank you cancer skins
four stamp
uh full thank you
chairman that's three for the
recommendation
three against the recommendation and
three abstentions
okay does that mean that i have a
casting vote even though i voted
yes you have then i'm going to
vote to approve subject conditions
thank you thank you chairman well then
then that's carried
that's that's four that will be four for
the
recommendation three against and three
abstentions
so that's carried thank you very much
indeed we move on to
item six twenty zero one two three eight
stroke ful
barn at little acre scots hill
southminster uh this is pages 33-48
please note that a member's update in
relation to this application has been
circulated prior to the meeting
i'm sure we will be told about that in a
second so i'm going to call on the
officer to present this item
but i just need to remind you that if
you wish to speak on this item
please make this known by using the
hands up function within the meeting
and i will then come to you in turn so
please keep your points clear and
succinct
staplehurst please it's your turn to
present a report
thank you chairman
planning permission is sought to convert
an agricultural barn
into a three-bedroom dwelling it's noted
that the application follows an extant
prior approval application
to convert the barn into two dwellings
this has until september this year to be
implemented
and is a material consideration in the
assessment of this application
and as stated please see the members
update with an amended
reason for condition six and
confirmation that a legal agreement has
been submitted in relation to rams
this is the location plan showing the
site
to the west and this is the roundabout
which leads
east into south minster
this is the existing and proposed block
plan
and you can see there's an existing
single story projection to the side here
which will be removed to facilitate the
development and this is the
neighboring farmhouse to the south
are the existing floor plans and this is
the part to be removed
and the existing elevation plans
the proposed floor and roof plans
showing the
dwelling and the internal garage here at
ground floor level
and then the upstairs bedrooms and the
upstairs storage area above the garage
at first floor level
uh the proposed elevation plans and this
is the
eastern elevation with the garage doors
here and the main entrance
into the dwelling here
and these are the plans from the
approved prior approval application to
convert the building into
two dwellings split in half here so two
three bedroom dwellings
and then just some photos um showing the
access to the site
from scotts hill and some photographs of
the building
some more photos of the site and the
view towards the neighbor to the south
and some more photos of the building
consideration is given to the extant
prior approval application and due to
this
the proposal is not considered to result
in demonstrable harm
to the character and appearance of the
area or in relation to parking or
amenity space
it's therefore recommended for approval
subject to the legal agreement
in relation to rams being agreed thank
you chairman
thank you very much uh mr stable hearst
and uh i'm now
opening the debate uh and inviting
people to put any questions make any
comments
uh i see no hands up uh who would like
to go first
uh councillor beal yes uh have you got
the south mr parish council
um reply to this application please
uh uh miss staplehurst
um thank you chairman um yes um it is
a supporting um comment
thank you very much thank you uh
councillor bell
thank you mr chairman um i'm actually
quite
familiar with this site because i want
my dogs at the
farm opposite and it's very close to the
enormous
new development of uh you know
generic houses which i don't know if you
quite pick up on
on the on the map so even though it's
slightly
outside the development area it's only
by a few
few hundred meters and i think we have
to be very mindful of the accident
planning permission
and i really can't see any harm at all
caused by this
to be quite honest so i would support it
thank you thank you very much councillor
bell
uh count uh are there any other
counselors who would care to comment on
this particular application
i will therefore ask if officers have
anything to add
and if they don't i will then uh propose
that uh we uh that this committee
uh goes with the officer's
recommendation and approves it subject
to completion
i understand of an uh section 106
agreement
thank you that's been seconded uh can we
do this by
ascent or do we need to go to event i'm
going to ask for a sent
can you please let me know if you were
sent
i agreed agreed okay that is
agreed and therefore we want to
apologize
oh sorry counselor uh you had your hand
up but
so you're now muted if you want to
unmute yourself that was the ascent hand
chairman i was banging up a hand for
a cent thank you very much you said use
our hands and you know
so
so apologies chairman could i just sorry
uh through you chairman could i just um
interject for a moment
um at the start of the presentation for
item five
um ms parker haynes read out an
additional condition to be applied to
item five
i just wanted to make sure that you know
for for clarity
that we had actually um that members had
actually
registered that so that was also part of
the approval of item five
uh my understanding uh uh is that it was
okay yes i thought i heard you saying
the additional condition i just wanted
to
double check that before we moved on
that's fine thank you very much very
much
uh item seven this is
twenty strokes zero one two seven five
stroke ful commercial area
bradwell marina waterside road rival on
c this is on pages 49-58 please note
that a member's update in relation to
this application
has been circulated i'm sure we will
hear exactly what it is from the
staplehurst
uh who i will call on for in a moment
but just to remind you once more please
use the hands up
function keep your points as clear and
succinct as possible
miss staplehurst thank you chairman
this application proposes the
construction of a workshop building
divided into three units to be used for
the carrying out of work on
large yachts including painting
refitting and repairs
at bradwell marina please see
the members update with an amended
condition
and there is also a verbal update the
highway authority have responded
and have no objections
this is the location plan showing the
site adjacent to the marina
accessed via waterside road
along here
at the block plan showing the
positioning of the three units the
floor plan showing the layout of each
unit
which is primarily a large workshop area
but with a small
office toilet and kitchenette
the proposed elevations with
this elevation with the doors fronting
northwards
some photographs are showing the rough
positioning of the building
uh the view from waterside road to the
east of the site
the view looking southwest towards the
site from the entrance to the marina
access
and the view south along the access
adjacent to the marina
this building would be behind here
and then the views of directly where the
building would be located
overall whilst the development would be
a large addition to the site
its use would be in keeping with the
marina use and provide employment
opportunities
and is therefore recommended for
approval thank you chairman
uh thank you mr staplehurst uh and i now
throw this open
for debate uh does anybody uh well would
anybody like to open the debate with
any comments on this particular
application
uh councillor stamp uh thank you
chairman
i think it's great that we are getting
some boat
um associated um
services and trades coming back all too
quickly we're losing it and i
certainly wholeheartedly support this
recommendation mr chennai thank you
thank you very much uh council channel
very much along similar lines chairman
um
i'm i'm pleased to you know it's going
to add benefit to our marine industry
i'm very much hoping
some young people we need uh young
people to learn
skills um and everything and certainly
to have an area where
yachts can be worked on in whatever way
it will
supply um employment um so yes i i
do uh like council stamp have to support
this wholeheartedly
thank you very much uh councillor chana
is there anybody else who would like to
talk on this
uh i see nobody so i'm therefore going
to propose
uh still no sorry counselor helm were
you
no no i see no one so uh
i'm therefore going to propose uh
that we go with the officer's
recommendation and approve this subject
to the conditions
uh that they have uh outlined in their
report uh do i have a secondar
uh i think councillor stamp uh and
councillor helm seconded but uh let's
let's take a councillor stampers i think
she was a
fraction of a second ahead uh and if we
uh could now uh agree with this by
ascent
use your hands use whatever you like uh
um if you would like to ascend to this
great great great both hands
okay great that's fantastic so uh that
uh
is now time to move on to item eight
uh twenty one zero zero zero one two
stroke va
our themes farm uh steeple remote south
minister
essex we uh this is pages 59
68. the officer will speak in a moment
i'll remind you of the process to put up
your hands be succinct
uh i now ask that we
uh just wait with me for a second i
don't do we have somebody yes
first of all we go to uh catherine
matthews and then we have somebody
a public participant who will be taking
part i understand so
catherine matthews please could you
present the report
i can't i can't hear anything chairman i
can't hear anything uh catherine i'm
afraid
okay thank you chairman um good evening
members
i can hear you now thank you
and i can't hear you uh you seem to
that your mic seems to be coming in and
out is a connection issue
can you hear me now i can hear you now
yeah okay
thank you all right so this is this is
uh
an application yeah um to very condition
19
over the outline plan permission um for
this site
and that condition related to
requirements
um for highway works so this is the um
application site
again location plan this
shows the approval layout for the
housing so the plan permission was for
94
94 homes and associated works
um and the plan on the left there shows
the
say the approved layout and the link
road around the edge of the site
and then we've got an aerial view um
which
it was dated about october 2020 so
things have moved on since then but that
was the most up-to-date
aerial photo but that shows the link
road
um around the edge of the site
and these are some photos showing what
what is there now so
the one on the left is looking north so
that's the area of the site that
um there with the link road section link
road that is currently uh
not open yet and then looking southwards
it shows the the new housing on the left
there in the
sixth and relic road which is currently
open to
um traffic
so the application the applicant seats a
variation of condition 19
um to delay the opening of that
last section of the link road the
current application requires the whole
link road to be open
before first occupation um but that
time has passed they're now asking
if that a delay could be um
allowed so that they could open the link
road after the completion or
within three months of the completion of
the 80th dwelling
and it's considered that the proposed
delay in the opening code would not
result in any undue harm in terms of
highway safety or accessibility
and essex county council highways have
also raised no objections
the principal reason for requesting the
delay is to avoid potential conflict
between the construction
between construction and
non-construction use of the highway
and as can be seen from the photo that
section of the link road
or either side of that is being used as
the part the construction
compound for the for the development
and so it is recommended that plant
permission is granted subject conditions
um set out in your papers um but
they're these are the conditions that
were also attached to the outline
permission but have been revised and
updated to reflect the details which
have been approved since the
sorry the outline plan permission was
granted um the
the data variation well the d duration
was also be required
to amend the wording of the unilateral
undertaking which was completed
as part of the outline plan permission
and therefore that
is reflected in the recommendation on
the agenda papers
thank you thank you catherine matthews
uh just to say
um we had quite a lot of wind noise on
your presentation
it may be that you need something like a
smaller version of this sort of
uh muffler or windsock on your
microphone that may help i don't know
it's just uh it sounded like air coming
from your mouth was
making it a bit tricky to hear but i
think we heard it all which is the most
important
thing uh and we now have one public uh
we have a public participant
for this planning application uh so i
now invite the applicant
mr chris webber to read out his
submission
i need to remind you that you are
allocated two minutes only for public
speaking
in accordance with the scheme so please
turn your camera on
and your microphone on now and when
you've finished turn them both off
if you would uh please uh can you go
ahead please
mr webber well do um good evening
councillors and
thank you chemskins for the opportunity
to speak today in support of our
application to very condition 19
which is the highway works at our
development site blackwater reach in
southminster
my name's chris webber and i'm the
planner for david wilson homes
as your officers have set out david
wilson homes have asked for a variation
to condition 19
so we can amend the opening of the link
road connecting the b1018 scottsdale
roundabout to steeple road
through our site this is because of
significant concerns over the health and
safety of both
on-site workers and members of the
public
if the link road was opened as currently
stipulated under the condition
an opening of the link road on these
time scales would result in construction
plant mixing with pedestrian foot and
vehicular traffic
over and above those which is just as
opposed to the normal site residence
thereby creating a significant conflict
of road safety and an unacceptable
potential risk to health because of this
the proposal is fully endorsed by essex
highways and i know southminster parish
council have no objection
the condition is currently worded
stipulates that the link road must be
opened prior to the first occupation
our proposed revision to three months
from the 80th occupation
would take us to august of this year and
would allow sufficient time for david
wilson homes to simultaneously open up
the link road for public traffic
and progress the developments
efficiently so the heavy plant will no
longer have to utilize the link road
thereby removing the potential for any
conflict and thus threat to health
as your officers also confirm the
proposed deferment would not delay the
delivery of our homes or prevent access
being gained to any of the new dwellings
by means of vehicle or on foot
and i'd like to make it clear that no
variation to the actual works are
proposed
and dave ward's names are committed to
delivering all the improvements as set
by the planning permission
to conclude this proposal has no
planning objections from statutory
consorties and we have worked
proactively with essex highways
and catherine to ensure the link road
has opened up the earliest but safest
opportunity
thank you very much thank you mr webber
uh i now open the debate and invite
people to
comment upon this application or does
anybody
uh care to open the discussions
uh yes councillor bell
thank you mr chairman i just uh it
sounds
sensible to me really and uh
yeah we wouldn't want construction
traffic mixing with pedestrian and
residential traffic so i think it sounds
like a sensible way forward to me thank
you
yes i mean i'm thinking that because of
covered delays that
we have i mean of course if in the
original application
and the stipulation was that it should
be open the road should open
when uh we asked it to be opened uh
that there was the anticipation that
that mix wouldn't happen but
circumstances have changed
uh could uh an officer just explain why
that change has happened again i know
that
it's in the report but why it is that
we've come to this
uh that we're having to make this
decision
uh catherine matthews
sorry catherine i can't hear you again
you'll need to move your microphone
towards you yeah
i don't normally use the headphones but
um it wasn't working without them today
um yeah so the the the applicant's
principal reason is
as we explained is um the area that is
currently
um closed off is used as their
construction compound
and they um don't want the
the they want the the risk of them
having construction traffic and
um non-construction traffic mixing
mixing together
and they should that wasn't that always
going to be the case
i mean what changed here
um the um
the the the kovid
crisis pandemic has has all has affected
the construction
industry quite generally and um that um
that
that that may well have been a factor in
um
why the things hadn't gone as as has
been as was originally planned and
obviously the the outline plan
permission was granted
a number of years ago now and um
so the practicalities of of constructing
the the estate
um in 2020 2021 obviously quite
different to
what was in business back in the um when
the outline permission was originally
granted
so um so this proposal takes into
account
the current situation and um
comes to a compromise between
opening up the link road to too early
from a practical point of view and but
ensuring that the link road is provided
and finished and completed and opened
before
the the housing estate is completed
okay thank you thank you very much uh
catherine yes i just wanted to
be clear on why the situation has
changed
uh i'm now going to sorry i just just
wanted to say
who's speaking all right this is michael
johnson oh michael sorry yeah
i just wanted to add that um you know
these sorts of variations with
conditions which are
tied into timing the the opening of you
know infrastructure or the use of
infrastructure and
bringing forward of the development is
quite common
over this pandemic period because of the
delays to construction
um the need for obviously the developer
to start to
you know bring housing forward um to
generate funds
obviously and then the conflict
obviously there would be with delay in
the construction work so
this is this is quite a normal process
for this to happen
um there is no implications in terms of
you know the impact on the delivery of
the scheme otherwise or the link road
thank you very much mr johnson i'm
therefore going to make the proposal
uh that we go with the officer's
recommendation uh
and i asked for a seconder uh will
somebody second that please
counsellor stamp has seconded that uh
can we do this
uh i see uh there have been no
objections so far so i think we can do
this by ascent could you please
uh make a noise yeah great
agreed thank you that's therefore been
agreed by
ascent we now uh is that
uh the case bernie you're happy with
that i take it
yes chairman that's absolutely fine
thank you so item
nine any other items of business the
chair may decide
are urgent i have none so i therefore
close the meeting uh at uh
1853 thanking everybody for
your contributions uh please don't go
into any further discussions
please leave the meeting promptly and
thank you all
very much thank you chairman thank you
mr chairman
thank you very much chairman good night
everybody